Hola Valentina pues muchos turcos están
muy enfadados con un gobierno que creen
que ha respondido bastante lento a una
situación que probablemente ningún
gobierno puede responder como este vídeo
de un terremoto de tanda de tal magnitud
con tantos miles de edificios destruidos
sin embargo muchos se quejan que esta
ayuda hoy mismo 80 horas después de ese
terremoto del lunes por la noche no ha
llegado muchos lugares sobre todo en
pueblos de mediano y pequeño tamaño en
ciudades como esta ahora mismo estamos
en adana y aquí uno de los sitios mejor
conectados de todas las regiones
afectadas los trabajos aún continúan Y
no van a parar hasta que no se
encuentren las más de probablemente
cientos incluso miles de personas que
están atrapadas aún bajo las ruinas de
todos los edificios de ruidos son casi
más de 5000 en todo el sudeste en todo
el sudeste de Turquía muchos de los de
los miembros de los equipos de rescate
aquí presentes en este y en otros
lugares nos cuentan que las primeras 72
horas son cruciales para encontrar a
alguien con vida a medida que muchas
horas la probabilidad de encontrar a
alguien con pie debajo de esos cada vez
menor ahora ya creen y aseguran que
encuentran y lo vemos Nosotros estando
aquí parados mirando Cómo funcionan
estas obras que la mayoría la inmensa
mayoría de personas y de animales
también animales domésticos que sacan de
debajo de los escombros son ya a
personas que han fallecido